Hey what's going on is bilborough's time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and I'm
just checking in on you checking in on
you but do do do to check in it [__] old
man get some [__] Kleenex and have
some fun and sorry I'm so sick of being
sick just when the [__] is this gonna
end
I woke up buh doo doo doo I had a
[__] coffin fit at like 4:00 in the
morning and you know I was upstairs I've
been banished upstairs
you know I mean like back in the day
when people had like tuberculosis after
the slumlords stuck him in some damp
dark [__] apartment for years and
years and years and then these poor
[__] tenants would die a lonely death
and then they'd build a statute statute
to the [__] slumlord or name a subway
stop after him
you know always that one on off the six
the [__] I came over the name of the
stop I used to get off at all the time
and walk over to the [__] I remember
everything I saw in New York I just
anybody had a statue I just started
looking him up on the internet but it
was all this [__] that they did but if
you went to about page three of four it
was the other stuff that they did oh
yeah people if I live long enough I'm
gonna do a show this weekend at the Fox
Theatre in Atlanta Georgia and then you
know what I'm gonna do then following
day you know what I'm gonna do yeah I'm
getting in a [__] rental car and I'm
driving over the [__] Talladega I'm
gonna go watch a bunch of [__]
rednecks watching their dream cars going
around the track one more time
one more [__] time hey stock car
racing gonna change now that Ford is
[__] phasing out all of their sedans
did you guys see that they're not making
any cars anymore they're gonna still
have the Mustang you know cuz what would
a [__] Taurus rent when they come to
LA you got to get the red Mustang
convertible and put the [__] top down
and drive around like a douche right out
you know what you want to hear you want
to hear some self-involved [__]
they're always talking about the
millenials you know what I mean you ask
a millennial what's the top [__]
social issue out there today and they'd
say lack of cell service you know in a
tunnel no actually they said climate
change and they're determined to tackle
the issue that's what I just read today
Millennials think that climate change is
the number one social issue of course it
is then they are 100 percent right god
bless them and they're determined to
tackle it
you know wait till they get a little bit
of debt under their belts way to those
banker cuts [__] get them under their
[__] you know get a runner on the
wheel you know wait till they get
married yeah wait till that happens you
start getting [__] nagged then your
priority becomes paying off my [__]
house and and [__] redoing the garage
so I got a place for myself but until
then until that all right you saved the
polar bear so I hope you do it I hope
you stick to hope you keep it real man
like whenever you see an old hippie
still rocking the long [__] you know
hair even if you went bald still has it
all gathered in the back you know
anyways what the [__] was I got always
goddamnit bill if you had tangents there
was something I was gonna talk about
there what I Brown was talking about
cold medicine being sick led me to the
cars Talladega all I know is that I've
been sick too [__] long and I've had
[__] things started wednesdaya last
week these are these new super Colts
because everybody takes antibiotics and
everything right and rather than killing
the virus all you do is slap it around a
little bit and it toughen up you know
what I mean it's like oh that
you know it starts to know you
tendencies he leads with the left
[__] jab always follows it with an
overhand right he doesn't like when you
crowd him in the ring
oh [__] somebody's calling me oh it's my
mother hey mom I'm doing my podcast let
me call you right back
then I anyways
[__] I don't know what I'm talking about
anymore
oh yes Oh Nona so I woke up at like 4:00
in the morning just [__] hack and
hack in a way you know you know upstairs
in the guest room that's where I've been
you know sent my wife is also sick you
know but she gets to stay in the big bed
do you see how that works you know with
the nice [__] master bathroom right
next door she has a [__] humidifier
going she's got her [__] Kleenex with
the you know you won't get a sore noise
nose [__] mist on him I'm up in the
[__] guest room you know throw my
drop my old drum DVDs and [__] blowing
my nose with toilet paper that's how it
works you know and you know what do you
see all you see is women just constantly
complaining about the way the way men
treat women and their positions to
society right this is a society right
what about me what about my existence
you know where's my ribbon where's my
hashtag how come I can't get somebody
fired you know I've actually been
winning arguments lately with my wife
it's been good you know it's caused her
to kind of like you know do a couple
things around the house that I've been
asking her to do but yeah I know it's
gonna go back the other way the same way
like she goes you got to watch your
temper and then for a few days I walk
around smiling like a lunatic before I
go back to Who I am but you know I
accepted for who she is
all right that's what you have to do
after a while you know all you ladies
out there you think you're gonna change
your man you're not you're not gonna
change him the best you can hope to do
is break his
spirit okay if that if that's what gets
you off what about all of that [__] yeah
how about a ribbon for all the broken
men out there I don't know why I'm
talking about all of this [__] it's just
[__] it always makes me laugh anyways
how about those Bruins hey bump up Wow
did I think we were gonna lose that game
seven you know when we started our
fourth [__] line and immediately gave
up a goddamn goal I was like wow that
reminds me a certain somebody not
starting to game crying before the Super
Bowl the [__] are we doing right then we
tie it up then we go ahead it was two to
one that we scored one right before the
first [__] period ended or something
now I was like oh boys three to two look
at that that's what I was it was one
nothin them then one-one us then they
immediately [__] scored like they
always did and then we [__] and we
went up three two two and I'm like okay
maybe maybe you know whatever and then
they score have two [__] goals
they're up five two three this is one
thing I've noticed about the Bruins we
don't hit anybody finally started
hitting somebody in the third period but
Jesus Christ when the other team is
faster than you he's supposed to add him
to try to slow him down
giving him way too much [__] space I
thought you know I thought Anderson
looks shaky in the first period so I was
like let's pepper him with some shots
there in a second and we barely got a
shot on him it felt so I thought that
allowed him to settle down what Jesus
Christ was I wrong
I tell you you hate to see it yet to see
it would have felt like fellow ginger
you know [__] as a game like that you
know I guess Torey Krug he was a little
bit screened but uh he left he let up a
[__] softie that next one would have
goal number five was a softie now so one
of the first three wasn't a good one
either
not to put it all on him
but anyways my condolences to [__]
Toronto Maple Leaf and Jesus Christ you
know and you got to give it up to the
ones that still have the heart to
[__] go down the Maple Leaf square
whatever the [__] they call it and stand
there knowing that their joy is
eventually gonna turn to anger and then
they're just gonna be part of a [__]
reaction video a bad one
but you have to go right as a leaf
saying you got to go cuz one of these
times you gotta [__] win I like what
that one guy in the leaf said he said
obviously it sucks but I think in the
future we're gonna be a team to be
reckoned with I always loved that
expression team to be reckoned with I
think they're gonna be you know full
freckle settles down a little bit they
get a little more playoff experience
I'll tell you what the Bruins need they
need a physical presence in front of the
net each day you know we we still
haven't made up for [__] Lucci dupatta
there's no we always had that runaway
[__] train that would just flatten
people actually we used to have like
three of them we just don't have that
anymore now a [__] fastest [__] at
least I thought we were till he played
the Maple Leafs anyway so now the Bruins
move on we got to Tampa Bay Lightning
part of that hotbed a hockey fans down
there I went to a Tampa Bay Lightning
game down there right I went with Forsch
we was sitting there and there was these
Florida northern Florida rednecks behind
us some of my favorite rednecks
I like rednecks you know there was not a
fix yet I'll fix it ain't gonna fit well
it'll hang off nice we were sitting
there and they had on the diamond vision
they put this little baby up there right
you know they had an infant up on the
screen the guy behind us goes look at
little baby I don't know why it just
stuck with us so the rest of the road
trip you driving over to [__] Orlando
dead silence in the car and the force
just be like that little baby it was
hilarious and it also scary just listen
to the guy cause in sound
right and just the fact that you know
his jizz can also make babies I just
wish that like your level of
intelligence made you also like like
your IQ should be the same level as your
reproductive like potency who's that the
right word like if you're [__] [__]
it should be a half-court shot that
you're going to get somebody knocked up
you know that's not how it works
dumb people usually have like that super
jizz you know they just stand next to
somebody they get [__] pregnant just
shooting out [__] kids that's cuz
they're too dumb to plant you know they
just lay it on the back but it feels
good it feels good well that's my belly
sticking out
why is my belly moving does anybody else
feel weird after that meal and then they
just [__] [__] the kid out on a sofa
I mean that happens that still happens
in America out there on the Appalachian
Trail
God knows Hollywood will go out there
and put some cameras on it and turn it
into a [__] reality show and next
thing you know we're buying it and this
[__] little kids sewing together
t-shirts with these [__] dopes faces
on it
alright that's what's wrong with this
goddamn country Jesus Christ I love all
these people taking the bait on that
[__] kanye west [__] he obviously has
an album coming out you [__] morons
relax has he lost his mind did she learn
anything with that Beyonce album well
she was acting like she was all annoyed
with jay-z and that there were all these
problems and all what the [__] everybody
just starts gossiping and everybody buys
the [__] album and they're still
together how many [__] times you
gonna jump on the hook
he's obviously recording a [__] album
there's no more MTV billboards are a lot
of [__] money why don't you just
start saying some crazy [__] that makes
no [__] sense you know and then
people will listen you next album I'm
gonna [__] do that
get my podcast numbers up what the [__]
can I I'm gonna just start saying
positive [__] about women you know I
think the real problem beyond global
warming then that swirl of trash out in
the Pacific Ocean
even worse than Isis well I got a text
message I dropped the phone Jesus Christ
Tiki Barber pick it up girl for Christ's
sake shut this [__] thing I think the
biggest problem beyond Isis and Isis is
a major problem I mean they're just like
the Third Reich if the Third Reich had
no planes of boats or really any
technology is white male heterosexuals
and their microaggression which is why I
have decided I can't even do this
because you guys are gonna [__]
retweet this thing and next thing you
know that'd be some [__] I don't want
to get involved in that I was going to
say that I've decided now I can't say it
cuz everyone's gonna get all [__]
upset it rhymes with man's ition that
would be the ultimate right if you did
that'd be funny if you did if you did
that like as a sign of solidarity with
all the pain that women have been
through that you actually went through
with the sex change operation and then
everybody called you a hero and then
Diane Sawyer interviewed you and they
made you a woman of the
year and then after all that cleared all
these women came forward and said you
were grabbing ass and titties all
through the 90s and 2000 then you'd be
like well I didn't do that
that was Frank um Francis and I just
right and then you're on the other side
of the issue and they'd be like well
isn't Frank still in there and you could
be like well I left Frank on that
[__] operating table
I never was Frank Frank is my white
slave name given to me by my white
parents Jesus Christ how much more time
do I have in this [__] podcast I
usually like doing these things man but
when my [__] head is all clogged like
this you know when I lay down in my
slippers having to podcast with a head
cold
then that's a day's work people now I
know you guys are out there doing
construction what the [__] do people do
nowadays everybody air-quote works from
home now which means they're out driving
around in the highways during the day
causing [__] rush-hour traffic you
know what I mean because they saw
something on Pinterest that they have to
go pick up to add to their [__]
wardrobe for their party that night
right
we should go back to making our own
clothes we should go back to that you
make your own clothes you grow your own
burgers all right you want a [__]
burger go slaughter that cow and then
you figure out how to freeze the rest of
that meat are you gonna starve this
winter if they're pilgrim I think -
something's go something like that's
gonna happen we're either gonna regress
to that after this [__] hits the fan or
this Illuminati stuff is true and the
robots will kill all of us and oh I'll
be amazing in the future right it's this
Illuminati City and everybody's dead
except for the Illuminati people right
and the other people that they keep
making they kept enough people right
with good genes that they make [__] each
other so they keep making babies and
stuff that they can use to [__] uh
you know as almost like a parts car you
know for organs when they reach maturity
I know this is [__] up right sort of
like West world meets a guy with a head
cold doing a podcast on a Thursday
that's how it pitched this in Hollywood
I come in I say hello everybody we do
all this small talk but bah bah bah bah
bah you know I breed the [__] room
try to figure out see where the laughs
are gonna be you know try to block out
the ice-cold person that douche was just
sitting there you know fidgeting with
their [__] pen and I would I would
just pitch I pitched the hell out of it
so anyways so then you have an
Illuminati city alright and they feel
like they've won but directional
actually prisoners because the robots
have the city surrounded you know and
they still have some robots the older
versions that are good you know that
still work with the people but the
latest update of the one what [__]
rogue and killed a couple of it was like
the first people that died other than
the parts people in like hundreds of
years so they hit the [__] shield
then I got this big bubble like the
Simpsons at one time right they got this
big bubble over the [__] city and
they stay in there with the older
version the robots and they're the ones
that have to try to protect him as the
[__] higher-level ones are trying to
figure out how to get into the bubble
and that's what it is and this weird
thing you'd have to root for these
piece-of-shit humans so then obviously
what would happen is you'd have a really
good-looking parts person like Ryan
Gosling and he ain't yeah hi and he
would he would somehow you know he'd
bang like the hottest Illuminati person
and she believed in him and then him in
one of the lesser robots would then
[__] defeat the next-level robots
while freeing all the parts people and
then killing the Illuminati people there
you go and you could you could finish
the story halfway through it and then
get everybody to go to the second one
right and then all you have to do is
just show up down at Comic Con we're in
an obi-wan Kenobi rope and
think you got a billion-dollar franchise
what do you think yeah you like that
movie what would you name that movie
Bill's great idea oh Jesus
what are you doing on my phone what
pictures that's it oh that's right I
forgot we had a kid come on you guys you
know so he puts 10,000 hours into that
idea you got yourself a good [__]
movie movie movie there's a lot of hacky
[__] in there you know it's like West
world meets [__] Moonraker with a - a
happy days you know cuz at some point
some Oh [__] Ron Howard directs Ryan
Gosling stars heap I wouldn't do it
because y'all redid Blade Runner do you
guys see that one the 2048 blade run
that moves movie was the [__] I just
noticed I probably made coffin-like
every five [__] seconds on this I
apologize I apologize but I'm not gonna
take a cough drop
alright cough drops are for Socialists
alright anyway so you know I like why
don't you do an interview when you got a
[__] show coming up they go bill so
what can people expect from you what are
you be talking about when I come to town
well you well I can't [__] tell you
that because then the jokes are gonna be
over everybody's gonna know what I'm
gonna be talking about what kind of
[__] question is that you sound like
you're still angry I'm not angry it's
just my book might default emotion I
walk around relaxed and then when
anything happens good or bad I get it
and I don't know if it's good I don't
get angry I don't know hey we got a new
advertiser okay we somehow convinced
somebody else to get on this sinking
ship let's see here from the halls of
Montezuma
to the shores of Tripoli I will type my
[__] password alright Oh butchers box
butchers box we're not talking about his
wife all right
butchers box now these guys actually
sent me a bag of [__] butchered meat
and I had a steak the other day I made
my wife cooked it huh
tell me I'm not running [__] in my house
I was actually sick and she's a
sweetheart and she cooked it and it was
[__] delicious it was a giant portion
so much that I've actually saved it for
a little bit of steak and eggs later on
this week
butcher box delivers healthy 100%
grass-fed and finished beef I don't know
what finished meats they are they it
means they butchered it free-range
organic chicken and heritage bread pork
directly to your door on a monthly basis
eat like you're in the Illuminati all
their products are humanely raised
excuse me and never ever given
antibiotics or hormones there you go if
you don't want your kids to hit puberty
at eight butcher blocks butcher blocks
put your box high-quality healthy
protein you can trust you can shake
hands with these cows 100% grass-fed and
finished beef free-range organic chicken
we've said this heritage bread pork what
is Ric Flair out there that's old-world
pork before they bread out all of the
fat and flavor to make it the other
white meat
aka this is pigs the way they were meant
to be I got to look up heritage bread
pork that's fascinating unbelievable -
it's like a met an old car with matching
numbers unbelievable taste there's a
huge difference in taste between animals
raised on pasture and those fed and gray
and constant and concentration animal
feedlot operations what your box is
changing that this is great there's more
and more of these types of people got to
love it
and they offer free ship
anywhere in this in the 48 states the
lower 48
Alaska who's kidding oh right your
[__] trap in your own meat in Hawaii
you eat pineapples over 20% off plus
free bacon by going free bacon by going
to butcher box.com / / and using the
discount code barbie you are our I tried
this [__] I ate this [__] I love this
[__] I backed this [__] butcher box.com
/ / you know got time to go to the
butcher use these guys I have to look up
heritage bread pork you know if you
former presidents always eating this
[__] right there we go
heritage bread pork heritage swine
definition it's funny what someone uses
the word swine and it's not an insult
I [__] love pigs there's certain
animals that I you know I like all
animals but I [__] love pigs ain't
cooler than a glut running around deaf I
like ducks
I like piglets emus freak me out dogs
are awesome cats I respect but you know
what I mean you know I there's never any
like sort of like every once while you
meet a really cool [__] cat all right
definitely but they got that Freddy
Krueger claws and [__] you know you turn
around real quick and they're like
practice and killing you you know you
catch them stalking you and [__] they're
[__] weird you wake up there on your
chest staring at you like that chicken
misery
alright purpose swine up at a part of
the American agricultural landscape
since the arrival of the new world
calling us this is why I don't read
books Moby Dick
get to the [__] whale sorry swine
indigenous to Europe were brought with
immigrants during the colonization of
America convention those [__] things
on the wooden ship
freaking the [__] out riding over there
with us hairless monkeys knowing they
got to get killed and the many different
types of swine they brought have
provided pork lard pest control and land
improvement services for centuries how
to pour kind of pigs help with pest
control because they [__] eat
everything I have something else to look
up this is how you lose a day on the
internet because there's always an
answer doesn't mean it's right but
there's Oh someone old some will have a
page that's what I think this Y is what
they do with varmints modern bred
associations maintain pedigree
registries of purebred animals for each
breed that descends from these colonial
oh wow these are like the [__] the
Blue Bloods of pigs as well as later
introductions registration of animals
destined to become breeding stock is
essential to the long-term security of
the breeds registration validates
purebred status of the animals and
assures their availability for
conservation by future generations many
swine's many swine's breed swine breeds
that were once core components of
regional cultures are now in danger of
extinction as cultures of home Homo
Chennai's homogenized God I'm stupid and
historic agricultural traditions
abandoned the flavors and food
traditions that revolved oh yeah check
on Monsanto for that one [__]
lunatics definition of heritage swine I
don't even know if it's Monsanto they
always the default people you blame who
knows allegedly
Monsanto heritage swine must adhere to
all of the following uno UH one ain't
true genetic bread the breed is a true
genetic breed of swine that is when
mated together it reproduces the breed
type alright I guess this is from Europe
to the DOS
what is it Einstein's I can't do the
German and dangered breed the breed is
or has been endangered as defined by the
livestock Conservancy and it appears on
or is recovered from the conservancies
conservation priority list and the
critically threatened Jesus Christ long
history in the u.s. purebred state I get
it it's purebred and I like it they're
[__] endangered and I'm eating them
I'm eating that [__] pig version of a
[__] bald eagle what the [__] did I
just I just shut that off and I I wanted
to what else did I want to look up what
was it out how do pigs control pass
population eat bugs not how I don't how
to bill how do okay
here we go nitrous is forbidden that
information was forbidden practical
feral pig control because feral pig
population of those are the wild pigs
anyways
[__] this [__] how are there wild pigs
by the way
well those the farmers that got scalped
by the Native Americans and they just
they're pigs just ran off continue to
[__] for centuries you know I don't know
I don't have the answers to these
questions but I do have some [__] I
have to do with 10 o'clock all right
that is the podcast this was a weird one
alright but we came up with a good movie
idea we learned about heritage pigs and
[__] swine from Europe and GoPro ins
and Celtics about those Celtics and I
trying to wrap up these pesky [__]
Milwaukee Bucks you know I like that one
guy on Milwaukee he looks like a [__]
like a mid-sized Manute Bol
really dark-skinned guy he had some
[__] layup or some [__] to go up by
four in the second quarter and he
shushed the crowd like he just hit a
game-winning three lose the second
quarter then they go on to lose the game
I just don't III don't understand these
kids today
all right everybody have a great weekend
you [__] and I'll see everybody in
Atlanta and I'll see you listen to the
music and enjoy another half-hour of
greatest hits from a Thursday just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Thursday earlier this year possibly this
decade all right I'll see ya
[Music]
Oh No
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday April 26 April April 26th 2010
how the hell are you I'm a little late
today with the podcast doing it 343 lost
angle A's time and you probably want to
like do what the [__] you're supposed to
be doing these Monday morning that's why
you call it the Monday morning podcast
so when I come to work on Monday morning
I have something to listen to rather
than focusing on the [__] job that I
hate well you're right LAN let's I am
late this week but you know what I was
busy [__] busy this week hey I was
doing [__] this morning you know what I
mean and also not to mention I am
filming this podcast for the first time
ever I am allowing somebody else into
the Monday morning podcast bunker until
now people just had to use their
imagination to wonder what the [__] does
Bill look like while he does this
podcast is he wearing a tuxedo maybe a
dinner jacket is he sitting there you
know I'm not I'm in pajamas and my
t-shirt with my little Radio Shack
headphones on does the exact way that
you pictured me but I am filming it this
week because my DVD is just about
complete and now we are working on
extras and I think at my last DVD I did
the I did a little short history a bunch
of clubs that I loved in New York so you
kind of got that whole background and I
figured out me I'll do this maybe I'll
film the podcast edit out the hours and
hours of unfunny moments right so you're
gonna actually hear the whole [__]
podcast these idiots who bought my DVD
who are gonna watch it just be like oh
my god this is the greatest [__]
thing I've ever seen because of the
wonderful world of editing so you're
probably thinking like what are you
doing bill you filming it yourself
and you're gonna edit it that that does
not that's not consistent with The [__]
that I'm used to listening to well
you're right I'm not I have the
wonderfully talented Brian Spitz is
working the camera yep that was him
right there he actually shot my failed
pilot last year on Comedy Central
remember that one that was funny we got
excited
we were like it's gonna happen was it
grow up with honesty was a great [__]
show wasn't it ever in the history in
the history of failed pilots I I would
say we yeah we weren't we were in the
you know we just failed as opposed to
just a complete failure it'd be like you
know if a passing grade was 60 I think I
think we got about 58 on that you know I
don't know you know the weird thing is
it's actually up on my IMDB page that's
what I love I don't know who put it up
there but you're not supposed to put
[__] on there that isn't on TV or wasn't
released in cinema or whatever and I
feel like for me I don't know how to
take it down but you'll take it care
okay thank you because people all right
well is cool can you actually can you
actually call IMDB okay yeah
but that sounded good all I'm gonna call
those guys I'm gonna call that website
and yeah I'll get those guys on the
phone to see what's up so yeah so if
you're ever wondering what the BER
effect was that was just a working title
that we gave it to him it never aired
and it won't air unless I become hugely
famous or infamous that's basically it
if I become a huge movie star or
television star you'll probably end up
seeing it in some form or if I go to a
mall and I just started [__] you know
killing puppies at the local pet store
or whatever the [__] you do I wouldn't
say shooting because everybody's done
the shoe anything isn't that like hacky
at this point you know what I mean
that's it's like it's like if I was a
comedian I went onstage and I started
talking about airline food basically go
walking in to a mall massacring people
yeah I think it's hacky at this point
you know yawn if I can be so bold to say
I'm [__] bored with that [__] but
anyways let's get to me in my big
[__] week do you guys have a big week
well if you didn't let me [__] tell
you about my big week first of all I
don't know if I've been talking about
this on the podcast as I settle into my
sofa basically everything that it
identified me as the person that I am a
month ago either
it was expiring or I didn't have it you
know I could not prove that I exist
with any sort of paper you know my
passport was expiring my driver's
license I needed to get that thing for
about [__] two years I'm not gonna
lie to you when you first move up to Los
Angeles I think they give you about six
weeks to get it and I've almost been out
here for three [__] years so and my
New York license was expiring I didn't
have a social security card that I could
produce I had the number you know the
Illuminati gave me a [__] number when
I was eight years old let's get him on
the wheel let's get him on the wheel
let's get him in debt are you in college
are you making 200 bucks a week hey
here's a Visa card we'll give you a
three thousand dollar limit don't worry
don't worry give us 25 bucks a week and
just get it up to your three grand limit
and we'll [__] own your ass all right
so I didn't have that what else didn't I
have my birth certificate I had nothing
I had nothing so I was like I was like
[__] I gotta handle this [__] you know
cuz all of a sudden now I'm doing gigs
in Europe you know I think I'm going to
Japan to perform for the troops I need
pieces of paper saying I am Who I am and
I have not done anything [__] up so in
one month I got my passport renewed I
went down to the Social Security office
I got that [__] thing I found my
birth certificate and the last thing I
needed was my driver's license so you
figure all right the driver's license I
mean that's a pain in the ass to take
the [__] test you know you ever
notice like what a [__] you become as
an adult when it comes to tests like I
think once you don't take a test for
what you're used to what is a kid
people are always testing you you know
we're having a spelling test run
vocabulary test some bully punches in
the face he's testing you you know are
you gonna be a [__] man
you know you Charles Bronson at age 12
or are you [__] Richie Cunningham who
I was and got bullied and sees no reason
to go back to a [__] reunion now it
wasn't that bad
you know what I'll be honest with you
when was it bad maybe elementary school
beginning of middle school everybody hit
their growth spurt and I didn't I still
had a high-pitched voice in a an orange
afro that wasn't a good look that wasn't
the look he wanted to rock as the youth
says so anyways I have to take my
driver's test out here
I brought it up with a couple other Los
Angelenos and straight across the board
everybody was telling me like they had
horror in their eyes and how difficult
this [__] test was going oh my god
dude dude it's dude it's [__] hard
it's [__] hard they kept saying that
remember I always lived out here ten
years ago I took the test it wasn't
[__] hard like don't do it I'm
telling you dude it was [__] hard
and I had this girl at this party was
this have you been to the DMV out here
oh my god it's not like the DMV anywhere
else la it's just like its own deal and
I kept saying well I've been to the DMV
I've been doing I know it's crowded and
she just kept going now now like you
don't understand
there's nothing worse than somebody just
tells you like you don't understand it's
like from somebody from Chicago when you
try to tell them it was a cold winter
and then they got to go on about [__]
now you don't know what cold is until
you stand and they're rubbing your balls
next to [__] Lake Michigan you know
like it's [__] minus 20 degrees in
Boston but still that's what you know my
family all came from [__] the Midwest
anytime I had a paper when I [__] about
the cold law let me tell you don't know
cold you know go to Chicago let me tell
you go to Chicago you said that all
those [__] idiots had some good
barbecue law dude you don't know
barbecue go to [__] Texas that's
where they got the bar like like they're
the only people who know that [__]
alright I got a little upset there don't
hold it against me
so anyways somebody's telling me I don't
want the [__] DMV is you know all
this does this just motivates me to pass
this [__] test and the first time so
I can just make so I can justify me
judging all these LA douchebags like
they're just mentally weak [__]
people so I start studying the test get
the book and it's like 90 pages I was
like [__] alright whatever
break it down gonna do 30 pages a day i
align this book yeah what are you doing
right now sitting in your cubicle
instead of working looking at your
spreadsheets what are you doing are you
here what I [__] outlined the book I
outlined the book 30 pages at a [__]
time meticulously like Tom Hanks in that
movie when he was chasing Leonardo
DiCaprio catch me if you can I was like
that that level of [__] and I was I just
you know [__] broke the whole book
down and then I sat there every day for
45 minutes to an hour and I went over
all this
in two days before the test Saturday I
actually took the sections out that I
that I still was having problem with and
I just [__] went hardcore in that
section memorize that and went through a
my all my outline I knew the whole
[__] thing you want to ask me some
questions you want to talk about parking
near railroad tracks I got a [__]
answer for you seven half feet if you're
inside a seven and a half feet you're
[__]
eighteen inches from the curb three feet
from a [__] handicapped ramp you know
one of these [__] guys rolling by
asking you for a quarter those guys
can't get like three feet close to those
guys fifteen feet from a hydrant you got
to start signaling a hundred feet before
you make a turn you get in the turning
lane you can only drive in if the 200
feet he can't use it as a passing lane
I had this [__] down so I'm like [__]
all these people I walked in there
confident I'm talking Kobe Bryant eight
seconds left give me the [__] ball
all right I ironed my shirt I knew I was
getting a picture that day for my
license gonna be nothing but success so
I walk in there I know what happened
immediately I start getting [__]
nervous you know like the first time I
did Letterman right like the first
[__] time you do anything I'm [__]
get nervous I've taken this [__] test
four different times took it in Boston
passed it
New York passed it came out of LA ten
years ago I passed it moved back to New
York passed the thing why am I [__]
nervous cuz these [__] la [__]
they have voices are in my head dad did
he [__] ha dude I [__] failed you
know I didn't forgot to mention is they
all said the same [__] why why they
failed it is cuz they didn't study the
first time because I thought it was
gonna be easy because they drive every
day do you really just think of how
stupid that statement is dude I Drive
every day I know how to do it it's those
little things you know like what is a
white curb meet you know you come up and
it's painted white what does that mean
loading and unloading of passengers are
picking up male yellow curb what does
that mean loading and unloading of
Freight if you're not in a commercial
vehicle the driver has to stay with the
car I study for this [__] give me the
rock it's [__] going in and we're
going to the next round of the playoffs
I was ready for that [__] and I went in
there and I maybe there was just the
overall anxiety the [__] place but I
do the whole [__] first of all I do what
I always do
at the DMV is I just blow off the line
and I act like I didn't see it and then
I'm some sort of like you know royalty
like I'm actually staying at the Embassy
for some [__] country you never heard
of I'm that guy you know when you stand
in line and you followed the rules and
then you get up to the [__] cashier
lady and then there's that douche he was
just standing there to the side
respectively half an inch just behind
your peripheral but you know he's there
and you can't have a pause in your
conversation because you know that
[__] gonna jump in that's who the
[__] I was I said hey I'm sorry buddy
sorry and I wasn't sorry that was me
really being like dude I'm interrupting
you right now and I said I gotta take
this you know I had a previous you know
a scheduled appointment where do I go
they call you going around the corner
whatever so thank the guy I wasn't
saying thank you I don't what the [__] I
was doing is just trying to prevent the
guy from punching me in the face because
I deserved it and I went over to go take
the [__] test and I'm standing there
and they only got like this walled off
area okay and this how confident was I
didn't even I didn't even brush up out
in the parking lot I was just like bring
this [__] on you want me to take LeBron
I [__] got him right so I walk in
there right and and you gotta wait to
think the only lie like five people in
there at a time so the first dude walks
out and you know they got the black dude
behind the counter like the host scared
straight you need to get your [__]
together kind of dude you know and I'm
just sitting there off [__] here we go
here we go this [__] guy this guy's
breaking hearts all day he doesn't even
give a [__] look at the look on his face
he doesn't give a [__] that Bill
Parcells look on his face right so this
[__] Indian dude comes up and he
hands and the thing and the guy just
[__] puts red all over it the guy
fails and then I'm like ah [__] the any
guy these guys are [__] smart right
Indian guys are smart they [__]
answer our phones over here I can't
answer phones if somebody from India
called me you know give myself a fake
Indian name these [__] people are
smart these people will run and [__]
until the English [__] him over right
this guy [__] passed but then I calm
myself down like wait a minute
this is a second language this is his
second language if I went to France
could I pass the driver's test [__] no
all right don't compare yourself to that
guy and then the next two came up and it
was a slacker the
white kid who had like tight jeans yet
they were hanging off his ass and I just
wanted to boot him right in his [__]
taint he passes so it gave me hope and I
went in there I got the test okay I get
eight hours sleep I took a deep breath
and I'm like here we go I have the test
right in front of me the first one was
some [__] about what is the legal
alcohol level you know that you can
drive on I'm like this is a [__] joke
I'm gonna Ace this test and dude I'm
gonna tell you right now after the first
question it just went down [__] Hill
listen to these questions I'm studying
all this [__] about how close to park to
a curve a curb and all that [__] you
must notify the DMV within five days if
you sell or transfer your vehicle are
cited for a traffic violation that's
Eaton that's obviously no paint your
vehicle a different color sound like a
[__] and read that part I don't
remember that part sell it transfer your
vehicle painted a different color
five days sell it transfer your vehicle
don't you have to [__] tell him right
then I won't they automatically know
with the satellites they won't see that
transaction go down on the [__]
driveway dude and then this is panic
just like and I and I and I was like oh
my god what the [__] and I got like six
questions in and I literally put the
number two pencil down and I whispered
yell I went really as I looked at the
black dude when he wasn't looking at me
of course totally passive aggressive and
dude I'm not gonna lie to you this
[__] test was brutal
it's a [__] brutal like you know
usually we take a multiple-choice test
it's like there's the obvious the half
right and then the [__] ridiculous
like when you drink a glass of water
should you a make sure you have enough
air in your lungs before sucking down
the entire glass and if you do run out
of air stop drinking and inhale you know
be smash the glass against your head you
know obvious [__] right this [__] was
like when is it legal to use a cell
phone I have the test right here without
a hands-free device while driving okay
when is it legal to use a cell phone
without using a hands-free device huh
you got an
answer a when making a call while
stopped at a red light that's obviously
no but here's the two close ones when
making a call for emergency assistance
or never
when is it legal to use the cellphone
hands-free people hands-free hands-free
device and there's all these [__] on TV
going if you use your cell phone that's
as bad as [__] drinking and driving
in the book it said never and it said
you could use it to afford to make to
make an emergency call after you [__]
pulled over and all that [__] look
for somebody riding a bike you know
looking for an old guy one of those
tricycles all of that [__] so this just
said when making a call for emergency
assistant it didn't say you pulled over
it didn't say you didn't pull over
so I [__] panic that I wrote never
got it wrong
alright this is that's [__] stories
taking ten times long and how long it
took me to study for the [__] test
long story short out of 18 questions I
got 15 right 3 wrong I [__] passed
the test but I don't know I owe an
apology so all you Los Angelenos this is
a hard ass [__] test it was difficult
I know what you're thinking like that
way you guys are all talking [__] cuz
you're relaxed right now right we find
another difficult one here highways are
typically most slippery this is a desert
question because it doesn't rain out
here and what happens is when it doesn't
rain for a while oil transmission fluid
and gas all starts to coagulate and when
it rains it's like I can't say it's like
ice but God knows people drive like it
out here but this this is the question
it says I would have [__] was the
highways are typically most slippery
during a heavy rainstorm in the middle
of in the middle of summer
all right middle of summer it's [__]
dry out you know maybe that's it then it
says when it's when it first starts to
rain after a dry spell well yeah yeah
after a dry spell absolutely but the
summers dry
what the [__] rights and at this point
my Mike [__] heart rate is going like
9,000 beats a second and then it says
after it's been raining for a long time
if it's been raining for a long time the
roads are wet it's gonna still be
[__] slipper
but I know it has to do with it being
dry out here so I [__] broke that one
down I'm like all right it's the middle
of summer it's a heavy [__] rainstorm
who's to say it didn't [__] rain
heavily the day before and it already
washed all the gas up so then I get so I
guessed when it first starts to rain
after a dry spell and I was [__]
right
but that's the level you had to break
this [__] down all right so I passed
that's it
they took my thumbprint the [__]
Illuminati you know sent that right to
the Rothschilds [__] house do you
know those sons of [__] actually have
the audacity the Rothschilds to have a
book about the giant [__] house they
bought in England off of all their
[__] [__] money from the rest of
us do you believe you believe the
[__] balls of that evidently there's
something beyond a mansion it's called a
manner that's when you have you that's
when you do take like [__] twelve
mansions and you put them together and
like people don't even know how to get
to your house like I can guarantee you
something right [__] now oh this is a
great way to see if they're running [__]
you know when you Google Maps I'll give
you a Google map where the [__] I live
not only can you see my place they'll
probably you can probably see my
brand-new social security card no one
gives a [__] about me but if you google
map the Rothschilds house I guarantee
you it doesn't [__] show up like the
goddamn White House because they're
running [__] and you know what they have
my thumbprint on their [__] wall of
the of their [__] nine-mile wine
cellar does that make any sense well it
shouldn't because I don't read all right
I don't [__] read
anyways what else do I got going on here
I wasn't bad huh for being filmed that
it seemed too self-conscious look at
that get a big nod eyebrows up I think
it's going good
the first filmed Monday morning podcast
this is what I do if you've been
listening to this I'm talking to the
camera right now not to you go back to
work you've been [__] off already for
19 minutes and 40 seconds this is what I
do every week I sit here in my it might
be my pajamas and my little footlocker
t-shirt you know there's this footlocker
I don't know what the [__] this is
footlocker like 87 t-shirts for like
nine dollars if you ever wondered if you
ever wondered hey
did a three-year-old put this shirt
together or was the person at least 16
you can never be more sure than when you
go to footlocker and you buy those
[__] t-shirts when you get like nine
of them for eight bucks that's
guaranteed that that's not even child
that's like toddler toddler [__]
labor be funny if I could [__] say it
so this is what I do every week okay is
what I do so if you want to listen to
the podcast go to Bill burr com click on
Monday morning podcast so you hate your
[__] job hopefully they'll be on
iTunes at this point they will be I'm
gonna talk [__] they're gonna be on
iTunes you know I have like 14 listeners
I'm trying to get it up to 15 whenever
there's no how the [__] you want for me
all right let's plow it ok I'm back I'm
back doing the podcast um alright let's
get to the stories this week uh uh that
was the first story I'm just gonna tell
some stories this week I got another one
for you I'm at this point do you want me
to pause Brian and go into another room
to give people something visually
different to look at should I do that
alright let's try to hit pause here this
is gonna be really quick for you people
listening at home it's like I'm gonna
pause and then we're back
so I'm pausing right now alright yeah
we'll put bookshelves and okay we're
back we're back we decided you know what
we already try to do this and I [__]
lost the whole podcast so we're not
doing it I'm recording right now what
just you don't need to record this you
don't you're not gonna use this on a DVD
this is just for the poor bastards at
home listening I actually so that's my
deal everybody moving [__] around my
apartment right now this is exciting
it's exciting to auto out in an audio
way to hear the it isn't I know it's not
dude you know what is there any doctors
that listen to this how [__] arrogant
is that like they have time between
surgery to listen to a [__] like me
well a lot of doctors are arrogant
anyways they save people's lives they
get that god complex just let you know
dude that's my water
alright that's yours over there okay
just letting you know I mean I like you
and everything alright you did a great
job on the pilot but let's let's keep it
there I [__] up the arch of my foot I
did it years ago from playing drums
trying to get my foot as fast as John
Bonham's having no [__] technique and
not having stretched so that that tendon
that runs from the ball of your [__]
foot to your heel every once in a while
I [__] it up in it and it just takes
forever to heal I don't know what I'm
supposed to do about it all right I
stretch I got the tennis ball rubbing
underneath it I know I'm not supposed to
walk around but that's what I do okay I
use my feet a lot of people don't you
know if you walk into a McDonald's and
you see those people that's what they
use their feet for to walk to their car
to sit in their car and then if they
don't even go in anymore they just drive
right up so I want to know what else can
I be doing is there any sort of aspirin
that I can be taking to get the [__]
inflammation down and you probably
wondered okay you're probably asking me
this bill because not being able to use
your foot is [__] annoying it goes
beyond that doctor so and so I'll tell
you what my problem is my problem is I'm
going back east for for a friend of
Mines daughter is graduating college and
I have to go to the graduation and I'm
getting a bet get getting together with
some people I used to play drums with we
used to jam with back in the day when we
all thought we were gonna get on MTV and
be the latest hair metal band the fact
that you had a redhead and a hair metal
band and then he could only grow a
[__] afro right there shoulda let you
know that you weren't gonna make it so
long story short we're getting together
and rather than going back and playing
the music we played in the 80s because
that would just be too sad to go back
and play my Michelle or whatever the
[__] we used to play well let's do
something more contemporary and I've
always played single bass drum and I
became a huge fan of Pantera and [__] so
I go let's do Cowboys from Hell and it's
got this insane double bass part and the
second I said that [__] I [__] up my
foot and I haven't been able to practice
and meanwhile the guitar play the bass
player they're all shredding you know
ignoring their children so and Here I am
gonna be the foundation of the band and
my foots [__] up so I need a quick
remedy all right I need something I need
something [__] quickly hear that is
there anything that I can take that that
will just you know I don't want to take
roids for my foot
coming there with my right foot twice as
big as the my left foot you know I don't
need that I have one big Jason Giambi
Roger Clemens foot and the other ones
walking around like Willie McGee I don't
need that [__] all right tell me what do
I take aspirin I leave what do I take
come on Podcast [__] free you can't
hook me up a little free medical advice
can you email me a prescription or that
just literally and your [__] days as
a doctor alright let's let's continue on
with the podcast as I sit here rolling a
tennis ball underneath my foot um the
next thing oh here's a great story for
you Brian you might like this do you
know I was a hero this week I was
actually I did something heroic
I have never I have never done anything
heroic in my life okay and believe me
I've walked by house fires and saw
people screaming saying there's a ladder
right there just put it up and I walked
away
I walked away pretended like I didn't
hear him I'm that kind of a [__] guy
um no this is the deal it was Sunday and
you know people hold a brunch on Sunday
I'm like I [__] it I'll go to brunch
I'll go to brunch right remember that
bit huh pace 18 dollars as fast is that
asbestos how did that bit go I thought
it was pesto it's asparagus I can't
remember so we go to brunch and you know
its usual [__] you want to sit inside
you want to sit out outside as a redhead
I'm always going inside
let's [__] sit inside I got enough
freckles I've had enough [__] pain in
my life please let's sit inside now but
you know I'm always with broads cuz they
always want to go to brunch it's always
[__] nice when they go to brunch it's
never raining is it right sorry all
right let's sit outside so we sit
outside and because I'm the gentleman I
have to sit with my back to the road so
I can brace you know and protect my
girlfriend and her mom in case a bread
truck comes flying in because the guys
text messaging or something right so I'm
sitting there and all of a sudden I just
feel it I just feel like something's
[__] wrong and something my caveman
DNA like when you get in stalked by a
saber-toothed tiger just kicks in and
something just tells me
to [__] look left and I look left and
here comes this crazy [__] lady and
I'm talking crazy I'm talking shutter
island' you remember that chick that
shushed Leonardo DiCaprio it's at the
secondly on our DiCaprio [__]
reference there you go
you remember that chick who shushed him
and shutter island' that's what this
girl looked like except with sort of
brownish red hair okay it's basically
one of these people who should be
getting professional health is
straight-up batshit crazy
and this just this state is bankrupt so
they just let him go
they just let these [__] people go
you know see Sarah McLaughlin whining
about these people come out and rescue
these [__] these people who are
talking to telephone poles it's all
about the dogs with her her priorities
are so [__] up it's ridiculous I hope
she sees this I am so disappointed in
you Sarah McLaughlin huh when are you
gonna grow up and stop whining about
those little [__] ass [__] dogs all
right that was mean
all right let's get back to it so she
starts coming down the street and she's
like she looks like she's gonna start
[__] crying okay like and it's just
one of those things you know you just
feel this [__] person's gonna do
something and I have a feeling they're
gonna do it to me so I'm working out my
[__] I'm like first fortunately the
chairs were these really light wicker
sort of kind of douchey brunchy chairs
so I was just gonna grab the [__]
chair and I was gonna smash her in the
face if I didn't have time or if I had
time I was gonna leap to my feet on my
bad [__] foot and out like a lion
tamer
ah get back crazy person right start
whipping her with the [__] tulips on
the nice beautiful brunch table that's
what I was gonna do so she doesn't lunge
at me but she walks by me is that awful
moment the blind spot you know what I
mean
where she's not to my left she's not to
my right she's right behind me and she
[__] goes by me and I'm like thank
God like I was seriously [__] nervous
and I look left again justice you know I
don't know why I look left again and
then I see this [__] sad looking
woman slowly following the crazy person
with this look on her face like she had
been wronged I ditched thing I know next
thing I
[__] no she's talking to the table
next to us and talking to us talking
about how that crazy woman had just
walked up to her reached up to her
sweater and just [__] ripped I know
she had a broach she just [__] took
it off her chest and walked away with it
and I'm looking at the lady and she has
the lady and she has this [__] hole
in her sweater where something had
clearly been ripped off and for the life
of me I don't know why I immediately
just got up I don't know why I have no
[__] idea why I deal with a final do
this [__] I get up and now I'm going
down the street following the shutter
island' lady with no training whatsoever
in this situation I'm literally walking
and now I couldn't sit down I couldn't
get to sit down like I I have this this
[__] Lee Marvin I'm gonna I'm gonna
make [__] right moment and then I go you
know what maybe I'll sit down look at
the biggest [__] ever and not only my
girlfriend that my mother's there so I
had to keep going so now I'm following
this girl and I'm literally I'm fine
never been so [__] nervous in my life
because it would've been bad enough if
whoo if it was like a crazy dude a crazy
guy is scary but at least you know if if
it gets physical I mean what are the
rules in that do you know Brian what do
you know you can't hit a woman but what
if she's crazy and she just stole a
brooch how about a jab just kind of get
a mitt in the face like Larry Holmes so
she doesn't see the overhand right
anyways I don't know what to do
so but I can't go back to the table
we're all gonna look like a [__]
infront of my girlfriend and my mom so
I'm like [__] why did I get up why did I
get up why didn't I do it why didn't I
say sit inside I wanted to sit inside
but I didn't want to seem like a rude
prick in front of my girlfriend's mom
like I tell her what to do like she says
kept [__] woman Saddam in this
situation so I'm walking down the street
and this is what I do she's on the
sidewalk I'm literally in the street
okay I'm like is that circumnavigation
I'm doing some police [__] where I'm
staying outside of whatever she can
throw at me scratching as one of these
people you got to get like a tetanus
shot if you roll around the ground or
hepatitis
some [__] so I'm like what am I gonna do
what do I do so I don't know what
happened I just said I I basically I
just started going hey yeah hey
sweetheart hey sweetie I basically I
think I started calling her affectionate
names from like the 1940s hey yeah
[__] tall drink of water and I finally
got her attention and she turns around
and looks at me with this crazy look
with tears in her eyes and I just say I
I think you have something that doesn't
belong to you and meanwhile this [__]
pathetic lady who just let her walk up
to her to begin with it's like he didn't
see that she was crazy that's why I'm in
this situation right she [__] she
ends up walking up to the girl in the
when I said I think you have something
that doesn't belong to you she just sort
of looked at me like in slow motion
lifted up her left arm and she had this
green pea soup looking sweater on and
she had the brooch pin to like just
right around her wrist and she just held
it up so at this point I'm like I'm not
touching this [__] so I let the the the
[__] victim lady with the sad
puppy-dog eyes she comes in and I'm
basically sitting there like an NHL ref
with respect for two goons that are
about ready to go at it right and I'm
just gonna jump in when I see that I can
jump in to stop this this fight that's
gonna happen without getting hit myself
and so anyways the lady starts unpinning
the brooch and the whole time she
basically followed my lead by being nice
she just kept going thank you I really
appreciate it I really appreciate this
and she couldn't get the [__] thing
off it was like one of those action
movies with like the clocks going down
for the bomb and I'm sitting there going
lady and my head I'm like would you get
that [__] brooch off this crazy
[__] arm and I just kept looking at
her right hand cuz I knew at some point
she was either gonna gouge her eye out
just do some crazy [__] right like you
know that the scrap metal that these
people put pick up and floss their teeth
which she was just gonna stick her right
in the jugular
so finally long story short she gets the
[__] brooch off and then we back away
it was like a uh exchange like we like
we gave some money briefcase and we got
the abducted kid back and we [__]
walk away and I'm like ah [__] thank God
thank God that worked out actually
walked back to the to the brunch
alright walk back to the brunch and I
got a [__] applause break from like
all these people eating eggs benedict
and eggs florentine was [__] awesome
I was a goddamn hero this week people a
scared nervous [__] dude I'll tell
you Brian I didn't come within 7 feet of
this woman I was literally you know you
know [__] the avenue out there like I
say where cuz I don't need psychos
knowing where the [__] I live you know
like I'm anywhere near that level of
notoriety
I was literally [__] like she's where
that wall is over there I'm gonna do
people who didn't know what was going on
they probably thought it was some
construction worker hitting on her
look at that [__] gams on her so yeah
that was my week that was my week people
I got my past my [__] driver's test
and I was a goddamn hero
huh huh what did you do this week you
know that reminds me what was that
shitty action movie that ended that way
that started that emaciated [__] that
[__] uh let's go say Brian Johnson
Brad Pitt's dating what's her name
Natasha wrote Robin in ski she's got one
of those I'm a hot girl names what's her
name
Angelina you ever seen a [__] ugly
girl named Angelina
Natasha Brooke that's like a hell of a
gamble you just know your daughter is is
his [__] is it's gonna be hot right
and she's gonna go for the money she's
going for the gold so yeah what was that
movie she did was she was the assassin
and the whole movie was kind of okay and
then the movie ends with blah blah blah
and then Angie goes what the [__] did
you do today yeah no no not mrs. mr.
Smith it was the one after that Morgan
Freeman was in it and they they stayed
shoot the gun in the [__] bullet
would go oh this is driving everybody in
a podcast nuts cuz they know the name of
it well then movie basically ends he
goes but the [__] did you do today I
mean they got pissed I watched a
meteoric a movie I say meteoric mediocre
alright whatever
go [__] yourselves okay this is with 35
minutes in 35 minutes in this is gonna
be like I said it's gonna be a DVD extra
and if you're watching this I probably
should
this earlier maybe we'll do it in the
wrap arounds not to talk shop I was
gonna say where the [__] you can go see
this get this podcast but here's
something new for some of you who've
actually found my podcast which I love
at this point to actually find my
podcast it's like a [__] test really
weeding out the computer illiterate of
which I probably couldn't even find my
own podcast unless I if I didn't do it
anyway so we have a new fan page it's
it's WWV mmm podcast calm ww capital
letters mmm P and then all lowercase
podcast com
I explain that bad the MMP are all
capital letters I [__] you WWE mm
podcast com go there
I definitely think there'll be some
pictures of Leonardo DiCaprio I make
references to [__] sometimes times
people don't know what it is the movie
that I couldn't remember the name of if
it's driving you nuts
that'll be up there and whatever else I
[__] talked about and as there's
YouTube videos and all that type of [__]
of which this week you know what I don't
have any YouTube videos I got to admit I
was hardcore studying for this
impossibly difficult test what else do I
got you want me to move again so we can
have something different where else
would I go I went from the the the the
sofa I was gonna go into another room
but I'm so paranoid then I'm gonna uh I
gotta stand up here for a second maybe
I'll be standing up here can you get
that can you get that with the camera is
this interesting to you people at all oh
here's one for you the conspiracy theory
somebody sent me something from from
England all right because the 14
listeners of my podcast I'm going
international with my failure was saying
that in England they're actually
experimenting with using satellite to
catch speeders satellite technology to
catch speeders can you [__] believe
that somewhere in the middle of that I
just lost all outrage I knew I was
[__] pissed I stood up my just
realised that was really hungry that's
that's one of those things that you got
to understand when you're starving to
death if
sit down it doesn't feel as bad you know
you ever watched those things when Sally
Struthers back in the day used to be
next to those starving kids and what we
just see they were always sitting down
or laying down and you think it's cuz
they're weak it isn't they could stand
up if they wanted to but you just feel
hungry there's something about your
pancreas sort of fills up that spot
oh [__] you I know I don't know what I'm
talking about um all right let's get
back to conspiracy theories here's a
conspiracy theory somebody sent me this
week somebody sent me this this week as
I put my podcast in my lap low level of
radiation going into my nuts right now
you know what they should sell they
should make the bottom and they give you
some sort of optional led suit with
these things you know I think that would
be a great thing if Billy Mills was
still alive if you could make like some
sort of cell phone LED helmet that comes
in like three different colors a manly
color color a womanly color and then
pattern there you go and then when it
becomes huge then you start putting
sport logos on it didn't they do that
with the Snuggie then you could get like
a [__] Snuggie for all those people
who get cold while watching football
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude I'm telling you man that's how I'm
gonna parachute out of this [__]
business I gotta come up with some
[__] and just you know I scream all
the time when I do my jokes I don't I
don't know if you ever notice this
problem but I don't know how to write a
joke so what I do is I say [__] a lot
and I just scream it you know and then
the the reverb of me yelling you can't
hear that there was no laughter
afterwards so I already know how to do
the Billy Mays thing so all we gonna do
is just come up with some hunk of [__]
old people old people that's what you
got to go like you ever gonna kill me
when I went to [__] Dwayne Reed one
time and I saw that booster chair for
the toilet seat I was just like [__]
that's brilliant yeah 20 million later
that's it people you start in a booster
chair and you end in a booster chair if
you're lucky if you don't end in a
booster chair that means you got hit by
a bus
and what would you rather do here's a
question for you would you rather get
hit by a bus at 42 banging some of the
hot-ass hot ass ass on the planet you
know or would you rather live to be 70
booster chair in the toilet
you know I've talked about this before
right your old balls hanging in the
toilet water that's why they have the
booster Cheers so your nuts won't hit
the water oh my god is it the 80s again
what's the deal with [__] booze -
Cheers
um yeah this is the podcast let's get on
to the next thing all right that was me
giving you a little button there this is
the podcast and we're out all right
conspiracy of the week bill you often
talk about conspiracies yes I do um this
may or may not fall into that category
but it definitely pisses me off I love
this guy already I don't know if this is
a conspiracy but it [__] pisses me
off
eyeball the eyeball with you so far
buddy all right I get my cable and
internet service bundled together from
Time Warner last month with my bill I
got an insane insert stating that they
were modifying their privacy policy
basically it states Time Warner reserves
the right to distribute my internet
content with or without my consent from
my understanding this could mean
anything from the searches I requested
from Google to the websites I have been
to what rights do we have in this
country anymore just venting all right
dude yeah absolutely
basically what they've been doing the
entire [__] time since the beginning
of the Internet is now becoming legal so
for all you people out there who always
thought like like I love when you watch
like those those talk shows and they
talk about sexting like we your text
messaging you know I want to [__] you
from behind whatever
why that's sexy I have no idea you know
do you think that thumbs tremble but
whatever I'm not gonna judge or like
they they talk about Skype sex and
they'll be like why do these people do
this why would somebody who had never
done always bring a psychologist's on
right they always have a beard so you
know that they majored in psychology
right and then they go they always say
the same [__] and they'll be just like
well it's the anonymity of it they they
feel anonymous and and in that situation
they they they they do things that they
normally wouldn't done well first of all
people it's not
anonymous yet [__] it isn't they
just saying it's anonymous they just
said it we don't think that they're
building a file on you it's all these
[__] morons who've lived a life of
the straight and narrow get on skype and
they stick their junk right in the
camera you're an idiot
yet done you're already done because
they're building robots right now to
replace all of us and what did you
didn't but they're gonna keep some of us
because somebody's gotta all their
[__] robot joints and what did you do
you stuck your dick in the camera you
don't your process that's over it's over
you got to take the driver's test I
wouldn't even fly won't even study
you're [__] finished you're gonna get
processed just like those people and
that [__] movie with that guy who
just died I couldn't remember the name
what's the name of the Patrick Swayze
was in it blood for Thunder new America
what the [__] was it called
here come the Russians pissing the
radiator all that all that hatred is
gonna gonna gonna eat you up keeps me
warm
remember that Ed Begley Jr was in it no
he wasn't the [__] uh the kid who was
in Seoul man was in it and he shot his
friend avenge me come on Red Dawn Jesus
Christ Brian you're a [__] director
do you get that man when you get let you
let that panic that brain panic okay he
just got it okay good I thought it was
only me yeah absolutely no this people
if you want to watch porn like porn the
porn industry is [__] he's going
through what the music industry is going
through right now
where all of a sudden the [__] just
became free all right so now everybody's
[__] whacking off on the internet
thinking nobody's watching what you
[__] rubbing your [__] out too
they're all watching and they're
building a [__] file all right you
think already haven't you noticed why
the president's keep getting worse and
worse and they keep [__] getting on
their knees and blowing the bank's more
and more it's because of the internet
all they got to do is break out their
internet file and show them some of this
[__] that they know that they jerked off
to and it's flights over it's [__]
over you got to do everything that
they're gonna say they're gonna expose
you they don't even need to take you to
Dallas anymore that's old-school
that's why Kennedy got shot in the head
if there was an internet he'd still be
walking around talking right now cutting
the ribbon at his [__] library
[__] his pants he would give the
eulogy at Fathead Ted's [__] funeral
yeah so that's that's what I'm saying
okay if you want to if you want to jerk
off to something freaky I would say go
to a porn store and just deal with the
fact that the guy behind the counter is
gonna know what you got pay cash and
walk away it's a done deal
but if you're gonna go on the internet
and do some of this [__] that you're
doing all you can hope now is that
you're gonna get lost in the shuffle
actually you can continue to do what
you're doing as long as you never try to
affect if you never try to effectively
affect change you know what I mean
that's that's when they break out your
internet file other than that it just
goes on a [__] database but the
second you start a movement going you
know what dude I'm sick of paying 25
bucks in my first bag when I get on a
plane if you get enough people behind
you
United will now go to Time Warner be
like yeah Russell Johnson yeah open his
file what is he jerk what's the most
fucked-up thing he's just that is the
end of the movement because then fox
news will get it and they'll just be
turns out Russell Johnson jerked off to
a [__] and a [__] last week this was
the guy who's gonna lead us don't get me
wrong I'm doing Glenn Beck that [__]
guy Jesus Christ I respect those guys
cuz they're in show business
I just wish maybe they can't admit that
they're in show business it's like
wrestling for the longest time they
couldn't say that was fake but now you
know at some point come on just say look
we're doing fake news we know we know
who's gonna win in the end of this [__]
that's all horrible all right well how
much time are we up to him 46 [__]
minutes for those you at home I'd do 50
minutes every week it's a free [__]
podcast admit it you don't like your job
maybe you don't like your wife maybe you
don't like yourself you need a laugh on
a Monday I do this for free
out of the goodness of my heart see that
Brian I've been a hero every [__]
Monday maybe that's what inspired me you
know what takes it away that you could
tell that
I'm an alum I'm a piece of [__] because
if I was a true [__] hero I wouldn't
have told you that story I wouldn't have
brought it up on the podcast it's like a
heathen I'm praying in public right now
I should have just done some heroic [__]
and walked away that's when you're
badass right
explosion you don't even look at it
that's what I should have done and I
didn't you know why cuz I'm a [__]
coward and I'm [__] blown away by the
fact that I you know bill it was a chick
he was almost funny if she weighed like
70 pounds that's the funny thing but she
was crazy that's that's mental steroids
when you're crazy they can all of a
sudden pick you up do the airplane spin
like sergeant slaughter did he do that
he didn't do that did he he had the
[__] Cobra clutch alright let's wrap
this podcast up with the overrated
underrated segment and this segment is
people send in stuff that they feel is
overrated or underrated they make a list
I comment on it and hopefully hopefully
it's hilarious I will tell you what is
[__] overrated he's buying a goddamn
shoe rack how you like me I ate to the
point where your feet have stopped
growing you don't throw out you [__]
sneakers and you got 58 of them and you
got shoes and you got boots and all that
type of crap I got all of that [__] and
they were filling up my [__] closet
and I'm like alright I got to get one of
those shoe racks okay but I need one
that can hold a bunch of shoes don't
look at the picture on the outside of
the box because they put [__] doll
shoes on those goddamn racks and it
looks like you can easily fit three four
pairs of breasts and then you come home
one pair of timberlands and a [__]
flip-flop and that's a whole level then
you can't take it bags this whole
[__] thing annoyed me that's
overrated
overeat is doing that just leave your
sneakers on the [__] floor you know
what when you go down to [__] uh I
was gonna say Grossman's go down to uh
the the Home Depot and build your own
shoe rack for a [__] adult I'm
literally sweating in my own apartment
here my me
am I gonna be sweaty on the podcast
circa me who is that who's this guy for
those people at home huh who is that guy
remember that coach I don't remember his
coach either but he coached the team out
in Vegas some of the teeth it was like
an old Elmer Fudd like if Elmer Fudd
[__] Don Zimmer that's what he looked
like Jesus that was insulting
all right hiss one from somebody
underrated Quincy the show Quincy the
Fonz and Sam alone get all the credit
forgetting the ladies but Quincy got
just as much ass as any of them it
seemed like he had a different chick on
his on his houseboat every episode he
was basically a silent assassin the best
part of it is that he used the word
broad to refer to the ladies those were
different times they really were they
really were Jack Klugman as Quincy that
was like that was the end of an era
remember that Brian you ever liked him
when we were growing up they did the
casting couch when guys ran this [__]
business and now look you know what's
funny is they thought if if they if the
ladies if they ran it that it would be
it would be better but it isn't it's
just is unbalanced the other [__]
direction now you got a bunch of [__]
on TV who are afraid of their wives you
know Ralph Kramden used to threaten
every week that's what I loved about
that show because they still shown him
being a [__] but he's still physically
Intimidator you know like Larry Johnson
he had that power forward respect on
that show that's all I'm looking for
just show a guy in a relationship who's
getting a little bit of [__] respect
you know all right I'm going over my
time here the last thing we're gonna
talk about is bad covers I talked last
week uh uh somebody mary j blige to the
cover of stairway to heaven and a whole
lot of love it wasn't bad but you know
what I mean I don't know it's just one
of those things worth there's some some
music
it's just sacred you know it's sacred to
you so no matter how talented somebody
is you're like what the [__]
so I was talking the last really bad
cover that I heard that it just really
just annoyed this [__] out of me
well actually I was in a gym and
somebody had remixed oh [__] did the
remix of sympathy for the devil by the
Rolling Stones you know and I'm gonna go
out on a limb I think Mick Keith and the
guy I think they got it right the first
[__] time these [__] [__]
first of all first thing they do is they
edit out the guitar solo okay take Keith
guitar solo out and then at one point
literally dropped out everything other
than Mick
Jaggers voice and then had some new
updated like like Casio drumbeat
underneath it it was just it's just a
[__] worst goddamn song I've ever
heard Jesus Christ bill how did I not
make that funny I really bombed with
that like I started off it was decent I
got lost in the middle of it you know I
got freaked out I was like what if Mary
Jay actually buys this [__] DVD I
went to that arrogant space you know
what it was you know what happened there
Brian I cared I cared and the whole
[__] thing went away all right let's
see hit last bad cover this here's one
from somebody and I know this this this
this actually this segment is starting
to blow up I just didn't have time to
put everybody so don't everybody's bad
covers on there I want to read these
because you guys really came up with
some great ones this week here's one
that he says all right this dicover the
cover song that pissed me off the most
has to be slash and Fergie's slash and
Fergie from the Black Eyed Peas
featuring that dude from Cypress Hill
there they actually redid Paradise City
and right there I was immediately going
oh no oh no he says all that energy and
swagger on the of the original
everything that made that song a
bonafide classic is ruined in this
version anyone that really holds up
slash as a god and trashes Axl cannot
honestly sit there and tell me that this
song does more to ruin Guns and Roses
name than the Chinese Democracy
what a horrible infuriating idea please
please give this song that's the
treatment it deserves on your podcast I
gotta admit I am a [__] huge
it's how big a fan of I am of slash like
I was right with them Slash's Snakepit
I saw Velvet Revolver anything he does
I will go [__] and see I remember I saw
Joe Perry project and he showed up and
he played with the band it was [__]
awesome I love slash but I got to tell
you this one then I'm not trashing slash
here because even De Niro has made some
bad [__] movies but here it is you
guys want to hear a little playlist a
little bit of this
I'm actually not worried about slash
saying this because we won't have the
rights to play this on
dvd say here you go I think it's been a
really nice podcast this week and you
should appreciate it especially a free
podcast from a hero such as myself I
just like saying that it's so [__]
annoying hey what do you do well I'm a
comedian and also I'm a hero I'm a
[__] hero as long as they're crazy
women and they weigh less than 70 pounds
I am right there to do my duty as a
stand-up citizen so here it is everybody
everybody have a great week thanks for
listening to the podcast and we're gonna
close out with the the Paradise City 2.0
I'll play a little bit of this [__] this
is slash Fergie from The Black Eyed Peas
and that guy from Cypress Hill you know
the the [__] trio that we've all been
waiting for for years they finally came
together and here's what it sounds like
[Music]
dude what the [__] already
what the [__] already
[Music]
right here you going okay maybe they're
gonna save it maybe they're gonna save
it
ah enough oh my god oh my god oh my god
dude you ever get like [__]
embarrassed for somebody else what the
[__] you know I I hate I can't
why do rappers always have to let you
know who the [__] is in the building I
can read the liner notes
we got slash in the head I know he wrote
it the Duchess Fergie ah that it that is
yeah that one didn't bug me as much as
Led Zeppelin I have to admit like
because when when Guns and Roses when
they came out I was like nineteen twenty
already realized I could see myself
becoming a loser
it sent music that you loved when you
had hope you know speaking of which
here's one for my my childhood I hope
for a speedy recovery for our Bret
Michaels man seriously man I know a lot
of people my ma-maa not like [__]
poison whatever you got a hand to the
guy they stuck around for 25 [__]
years and dies in the hospital right now
so I hope that guy comes out better than
[__] ever and that's it
see that's what a hero does he brings it
around to a nice moment that's the
that's a podcast for this week please
tune in next week please keep all the
questions comments and all that stuff
coming I really appreciate it have a
great week and that's it take it easy
[Music]
you